sorry to interrupt are you okay I need
to get out of a toxic relationship
why don't you start by telling us what
brought you here
my boss is different you can't get him
out of your head no I need your
assistance I'm coming Martha oh you feel
like you could straw you with the snap
of his fingers wouldn't even need to
snap
okay oh that sounds familiar yeah what
[Music]
I want a hundred of nuns a bus load of
cheerleaders
and I just went to normal life again
[Applause]
This Modern World Is A Dangerous Place
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you you saved my life did I watch
you cut a guy with a decorative serving
platter it's all in the rest
let me explain my boss gave me this
power
in return I tend to his needs including
care feeding you bring them people to
eat
[Music]
you're like the guy that gets the
villains Postmates but if you were to
stop focusing on his needs what would
happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power what that's so
weird why would you phrase it like that
but yes
are you here for the meeting well come
on no no
no others the Lord of deaths to most
I am
Direction
okay obviously we're dealing with a
little bit more than just narcissism
here
[Music]
[Music]